The Joe Rogan Experience please detail
the journey that you went on to to write
this book and why it's of concern to you
yeah okay well
um I started traveling to the Congo
um five years ago I've been doing
research on slavery and child labor for
about 20 years traveling all around the
world documenting slaves and child
laborers human trafficking
and this came across my radar
um maybe seven years ago people started
talking in the field about Cobalt
Cobalts and the batteries it's in the
Congo the conditions are horrible and I
had no idea I never heard of this so I
started planning to take trips to get
down there and I took my first trip back
in 2018
my plan was I thought I would try to lay
the groundwork to do some academic
research
um and the things I saw there
were so appalling and heart-wrenching
and urgent that uh I changed my Approach
I thought people need to know about this
um I need I need to write a book
uh and then so I started planning more
trips and I just kept going back and the
reason this is important Joe and we can
dig into this
in more depth
um throughout the whole history of
slavery I mean I'm going back centuries
never never in human history has there
been more suffering that generated more
profit and was linked to the lives of
more people around the world ever ever
in history than what's happening in the
Congo right now and the reason I say
that is this
the Cobalt that's being mined in the
Congo
is in every single lithium-ion
rechargeable battery manufactured in the
world today every smartphone every
tablet every uh laptop and crucially
every electric vehicle
um so you and I we can't function
on a day-to-day basis without Cobalt and
three-fourths of the supply is coming
out of the Congo
um and it's being mined in appalling
heart-wrenching dangerous conditions
um and so that's why people need to know
because uh by and large the world
doesn't know what's happening in the
Congo
it's something that people sort of know
peripherally that you know that they
call them conflict minerals and you know
they know that that they're coming from
an area of the world that's very poor
but I don't think people are aware of
how horrible it is there has been have
been some documentaries that have been
done on it and they're all terrifying
yes so so conflict minerals was phase
one and that's actually not Cobalt
um what is what what's term what does it
refer to conflict so conflict minerals
uh also called the 3tg minerals are 10
tungsten tantalum and gold
um and those are in the Eastern Congo
and that
um catastrophe started uh around the
year 2000 uh late 1990s 2000.
um shortly after the Rwandan genocide
um the militias moved in and Eastern
Congo is sitting on some of the largest
reserves in the world of those three TG
minerals especially tantalum
and those are all used in
microprocessors and you can think back
to you know around the year 2000 mobile
phones first started coming out and
gaining traction I still remember my
little star tack flip phone that I had
from Motorola you remember that sure uh
and all that Supply was coming out of
Eastern Congo militias and Warlords were
forcing the local population at gunpoint
machete point to dig this stuff out and
it was flowing up into the formal supply
chain into mostly those first generation
cell phones and that became known as
conflict minerals uh Cobalt started
later
Cobalt really took off about 10 12 years
ago and it's in another part of the
country in the mining provinces in the
southeast of the Congo and Cobalt took
off because it was started to be used in
Lithium-ion batteries to maximize their
charge and stability
and it just so happens that the Congo
just as it was sitting on more than half
the world's reserves of koltan and of
course a lot of gold and diamonds and
other things
is sitting on more Cobalt than the rest
of the planet combined
and it's in a small little patch of the
Congo Southeastern Corner a part that
used to be called katanga
and uh before anybody knew what was
happening Chinese government Chinese
mining companies took control of almost
all the big mines
um and the local population has been
displaced uh is under duress and they
dig in absolutely sub-human
gut-wrenching conditions for a dollar a
day feeding Cobalt up the supply chain
into all the phones all the tablets and
especially electric cars
and we're looking at a video now Jamie
what is this the Minds What's his video
so I think so this is so crazy to see
this is the bottom of the supply chain
of your iPhone of your Tesla of your
Samsung I mean I'm just naming those
companies right it's all of them right
all of them we're not just picking on
them and here's what you need to know
Joe about this video
I was the first Outsider to get into
this mine uh and that's why it's just a
really short video that I was able to
take
this is an industrial Cobalt mine where
there's not supposed to be one artisanal
minor now that's the term used for
people who are just digging by hand as
opposed to tractors and excavators
there's not supposed to be one here
that's what the story is told at the top
of the chain this mine and I can name it
it's called shibara there's not supposed
to be one artisanal Miner here according
to the consumer-facing tech companies
and EV companies buying this Cobalt lo
and behold I walk into this place and
this is what I see
there's more than 15 000 human beings
crammed into that pit digging by hand
and if you have sound you hear the
mallets you hear the shouting you hear
the the grunts it's a massive Humanity
you might expect to see a scene like
this
so there's a term that gets used clean
Cobalt there's no clean Cobalts not real
no no it's all marketing it's all PR
it's a fiction just like that place
there's not supposed to be any artisanal
mining there it's all done industrially
that's the that's the story told at the
top of the chain and people assume
people I mean the marketing teams at Big
Tech and EV companies assume well who's
going to go down there and actually walk
into the place and grab a video that
shows no it's actually all raw human
force that is clanking that Cobalt out
of the ground so there's no clean Cobalt
I there's not a single company on planet
Earth that makes a device that has a
rechargeable battery in it that can
reliably and justifiably claim that
their Cobalt isn't coming from sources
like that
and that's the truth that needs to get
out there that's the truth people need
to understand
um because this is a story that goes
back Generations there's these fictions
told at the top of the chain about what
conditions are like at the bottom
and Truth Seekers have to go find that
truth and Enlighten civilization so that
people people get agitated about it and
want to do something about it so there's
no clean Cobalt let's just make that
totally abundantly clear uh and anyone
that claims otherwise uh is either
peddling in falsehoods or is recklessly
ignorant of the truth
are there any
industrialized Cobalt mines that use
machinery and don't use slavery and
don't use child labor and don't use
these people that live in
unimaginable poverty I've never seen one
and I've been to almost all the major
industrial Cobalt mines here's why I say
that number one
they all or almost all will have scenes
like that on them
thousands of individuals clanking away
for a dollar or two a day okay they
don't have uh safety equipment all that
stuff that Cobalt's toxic toxic to
breathe and they're breathing it in all
day no masks no masks filtration no
gloves no half those guys are in
flip-flops
all right so
um uh almost all the industrial mines
will have scenes like that
so that's number one they'll say they're
no artisanal miners there no children
there and if you like zoom in you'll see
that amongst that sea of humanity there
are thousands of kids teenage boys in
this case because that requires a
certain amount of force to to Clank away
in that pit
um number two
there are hundreds of other artisanal
mining sites scattered in the mining
provinces outside of industrial mines
the artisanal miners in the industrial
mines and then just on the other side of
the fence there'll be a sea of humanity
digging there as well because it's not
like at the fence The Ore body stops
there's copper Cobalt other things
outside as well so there'll be hundreds
of sites where there are hundreds of
thousands of people across the mining
provinces digging
um
all that production
is sold right back to the industrial
mining companies
so it enters their supply chain as well
and then so they take what they extract
with Industrial Equipment artisanal
miners inside the mine artisanal miners
including children outside the mine it
all gets dumped together into the same
batch of acids to process and then flows
up the chain and again no one can
reasonably claim
that their Cobalt even if they say that
industrial mind totally clean don't
believe what Siddharth is saying that's
a that's a made-up fake video
they can't demonstrate reliably that all
the other Cobalt being dug up by kids
and thousands of sites across the mining
provinces isn't also flowing into their
supply chain
is there another source of cobalt in the
world that's ethically supplied
so um
last year so 2021 is the last year
there's data about 72 percent almost
three-fourths of the world's supply of
cobalt came out of a small patch of the
Congo
and
then there's like three percent Russia
three percent Australia three percent
Morocco you know there's everyone else
is three percent
um and I don't know what the conditions
are there I imagine in Australia mining
follows standards of dignity and decency
and labor and sustainability and so on
um but there's not enough Cobalt outside
of the Congo to meet demand and demand
projections are four or five six hundred
percent increase in Cobalt demand in the
next decade or two primarily being
driven by adoption of electric vehicles
each battery pack in an EV requires up
to 10 kilograms of refined Cobalt that's
a thousand times what's required for a
smartphone
so huge demand uh as the world
transitions from uh internal combustion
engines to electric vehicles which is a
net good thing except for the people in
the Congo
uh so there's not enough other Cobalt
out there even if all the non-congo
Cobalt was perfectly sourced there's not
enough other Cobalt out there to meet
demand
these companies that we talked about
that use all this stuff whether it's
electric vehicle companies or cell phone
manufacturers
obviously they're aware of this yes no
question they have to be have they made
any attempts to mitigate this in any way
the truth Joe is no not sufficient
efforts
most of what is done is PR statements
marketing all these companies will say
we have zero tolerance policies on child
labor
we ensure standards of dignity and human
rights for every member of our supply
chain down to the mining level they'll
all say this down to the mining level
um and they say it
uh and they may throw some money at the
odd NGO or uh Coalition or Alliance
that's meant to be working on these
things nothing's actually happening on
the ground
uh and that's what my book will
demonstrate you know as as I take the
reader on the journey from place to
place mind to mind
um there's this fiction that exists
outside of the Congo of what companies
are doing and what the conditions are
like and then there's the reality
underneath the those layers of
obfuscation there's the reality there's
the truth on the ground
um and not one company not one business
Alliance not one uh entity up the chain
is doing remotely enough
to ensure that the the dignity and human
rights of the people of the Congo
not to mention the environment
because although mining companies are
just polluting and clear-cutting forests
to build and expand mines
they're not doing nearly enough to
respect the people in Earth of the Congo
um while we outside enjoy our you know
renewable gadget-driven lifestyles